a major threat to the iconic Georgia
Peach the state known as the peach state
because normally the crop grows great
there in fact Georgia produces more than
130 million pounds of peaches every
single year but not this year 90 percent
of the state's crop has been lost
Farmers blame a warm winter part of a
changing weather pattern that seems to
be here to stay Mark Strassman traveled
to the heart of the peach problem
this is my great-grandfather's Farm
Lawton Pearson's Family Farm has grown
peaches for more than a century but this
year's harvest the worst in his lifetime
you've got peaches here
and that variety has nothing
not one not not a single Peach huh
that's the way 95 of the farm looks his
1500 acre Peach crop nearly a total loss
you always hold on to Hope until it hits
you in the face that there's nothing
here sounds like the different stages of
grief that's pretty much right I mean
they all died they're all my buddies
they all died and now I got to deal with
it
Pearson's losing an annual challenge
it's something called chill hours his
Georgia Peaches always a diva fruit
generally need 850 hours under 45
degrees Fahrenheit to Blossom this
year's crop with a climate change about
700 chill hours and why aren't you just
willing to say okay it's a one-off I'm
hoping I can say that I want to say that
but
we are
20 off since 2016. a warm winter plus
back to back devastating frosts that
killed off the Early Blooms Farm to
Table Georgia Peaches this year forget
it at Atlanta's Silver Skillet
Restaurant owner Teresa Breckenridge
says the cost of fresh peaches has
tripled I can't afford the peaches right
now and the ones that you would buy even
if you could afford them they're just
not good and a restaurant's peach
cobbler they've had to switch to canned
peaches there's nothing better than
fresh but you just have to have a plan B
with a changing climate Georgia farmers
are searching for their own plan B and
it could look like this each one of this
is actually a pit from the fruit that we
Harvest from a cross that we made at the
University of Georgia Dario Chavez tries
to breed a more resilient Peach his
team's matchmaking slivers from the pits
of different varieties selection
criteria size color and especially taste
so some of these are hybrids with
material from Florida but all good
breeding takes time and Georgia is
running out it actually takes decades
the short answer is you're working on it
yeah we're working on it continuing to
grow peaches
it's potentially a risk yeah it is
potential at risk you know we can't
adapt without new varieties but the
number one qualification to be a Georgia
Peach salad eats I don't care how pretty
it is or how tough it is or if it's a
you know if it's bulletproof if it
doesn't eat well I'm out of business
either way in all his unfruited trees
those were killed but they didn't have
the decency to fall off they just sat
there Lawton Pearson worries about his
future in Peach farming if we are unable
to continue to make peaches consistently
it you really start to question whether
this is a viable Enterprise I challenge
both economic and existential Georgia
the no Peach State
for CBS mornings Mark Strassman Fort
Valley Georgia
look at that number guys 90 of the peach
crop on your thing I mean Peach upside
down cake Peach salad peach cobbler
people make a peach cobbler in Georgia
with canned peaches this is a status sad
State of Affairs really is uh and
hopefully I mean I also worry about just
his livelihood yeah bullying for him
really liked him yeah story very well a
great piece by Mark Strassman as always